on a vu pas mal puisé meinau première
expérience à nos premières visions d'une
tique engorgé sur quelqu'un ce pôle fort
dans cette pharmacie du coin de ville on
a ce qu'il faut pour retirer les tic des
patients arrivent parfois sans trop
savoir quoi faire
qu'on s'attendait pas non plus comme un
si gros boum cus
mais après sa suite aux questions des
patients mais l'on affine notre autre
information la partage aussi en
collègues autour de 300 personnes ont
consulté ici l'an dernier la moitié
d'entre elles ont reçu de la doxycycline
pour la prophylaxie l'optronique deux
comprimés auront à bulle celle
antibiotiques recommandés en prévention
lorsqu'une tic s'accroche plus de 24
heures à la peau dans les zones où la
borréliose de lyme est présente
ça peut se faire au niveau de la
pharmacie on n'a pas besoin d'eux
d'avoir une consultation médicale pour
évaluer le risque associé à la piqûre
celle ordonnances collectives autorisé
par la direction de santé publique de
l'estrie et celle de la montérégie qui
permet aux pharmaciens de prescrire
l'antibiotique ce service-là devrait
disponible dans plusieurs régions parce
que le lexique est de plus en plus
présente comme on pense par exemple à la
mauricie centre du québec où nous tawaké
près de l'ontario ce médecin croit que
la recherche a encore bien des réponses
à fournir sur la maladie notamment
expliquer la baisse du nombre de
personnes infectées au québec en 2018
219 par rapport à 249 l'année précédente
est-ce que la prophylaxie le médicament
est repris en prévention a pu jouer un
rôle dans tout ce je pense que
certainement ça peut être une option à
envisager
est-ce que aussi cette année-là 2018 est
squelettique et est moins active est ce
qu'on a eu des ddd période de canicule
prolonger le fait aussi que le public en
sait davantage c'est décapant de
reconnaître une tique de pouvoir
l'identifier sur soi sur ses enfants
comme les enfants avec moi
les autres de mettre les bords par
dessus les jeans d'europe et on prend
les choses avec le dit dès le mois
d'avril
la nef de l'attique qui a hiverné est
prête à mordre ici anne louise despatie
radio-canada en montérégie